♪ ♪ ♪
- Le petit Ricardo est né en
plein confinement. Son univers
social limité à quatre
personnes.
JULIE HLAVACEK-LARRONDO, mère de
Ricardo, Sofia, Alejandro
- Notre troisième est né en
janvier, trois jours après
le couvre feu. Donc, ça a été
tout un ajustement .
(rires)
Même la grossesse était
différente, on était plus seuls,
plus isolés.
- Déjà parents de deux enfants
de 6 et 3 ans, Julie Hlavacek-
LaRondo et Rodrigue Khalil
observent des particularités
chez leur bébé de 8 mois.
RODRIGUE KHALIL, père de
Ricardo, Sofia, Alejandro
- Au même âge, son grand frère
et sa grande soeur  étaient très
attachés à leurs grands-parents,
avaient hâte de les voir,
s'amuser avec eux, mais lui,
le laisser tout seul avec
les grands-parents, on dirait
que c'est une épreuve pour lui.
Il pleure, il fait des crises.
Ça brise le coeur de ses grand-
parents. Ça nous brise le coeur
- Leurs observations concordent
avec celles de plusieurs
éducatrices en garderie.
MARIE-CLAUDE GAGNON
directrice, CPE Tortue têtue
- Des parents plus anxieux,
plus inquiets, des bébé qui
était très accrochés à leurs
parents parce qu'ils avaient été
en bulle juste avec maman,
avec papa. Peu de contacts avec
l'extérieur, donc des enfants
plus craintifs.
NATHALIE BIGRAS, Équipe
recherche Qualité des contextes
éducatifs de la petite enfance
- Les discussions que j'ai eues
avec certaines éducatrices et
directrices, c'est on nous
parlait de bébés-bras, qui
demandent plus les bras, qui
demandent plus d'être pris,
demande plus d'être rassurés.
On m'a raconté qu'y avait
des enfants que ça leur a pris
de novembre à mars à s'adapter.
- Ils semblent plus craintifs,
plus sensibles au bruit. Pas
étonnant que les chercheurs en
Petite enfance s'intéressent
aux poupons qui sont nés pendant
le confinement.
MIRIAM BEAUCHAMP, chercheuse,
CHU Sainte-Justine
- C'est une période qui est
vraiment importante au niveau
du développement social. Une
période où l'enfant apprend
à regarder les gens, à décoder
les émotions, à reconnaître
les intentions de quelqu'un
par leurs yeux, par leur bouche
par exemple.
- Pour appuyer ces premiers
échanges qui passent surtout
par l'expression du visage,
les éducatrices masquées parlent
continuellement à l'enfant.
- On va se promener, oui?
CLAUDIA BEAUDIN,
DG, CPE L'attrait mignon
- L'éducatrice va toujours
nommer ce qu'elle fait, donc
pour les enfants c'est
rassurant. On a quand même
toujours essayé de sortir
la pandémie de nos murs. Oui,
on avait des masques, on avait
du purell, on avait dse
sarreaux, mais la qualité
de notre travail n'a pas été
compromise.
- Des bébés différents peut-
être, mais qui auront développé
autre chose.
- Le fait que les enfants ont
été confinés avec leurs parents
n'est pas quelque chose de
négatif. Dans le sens que
l'enfant, ça lui a permis
de développer un net attachement
profond avec son parent,
un attachement significatif.
Et ça, c'est précieux dans
la vie d'un poupon. Ça lui donne
confiance en lui, ça lui permet
d'explorer.
- Tu y vas? Elle dit oui, mais
j'ai comme un obstacle.
- Avec la vaccination
et le déconfinement, les choses
se passent mieux .
MARIE-CLAUDE GAGNON,
directrice, CPE Tortue têtue
- On est en processus
d'integration depuis la mi-août,
puis ça n'a rien a voir avec
l'année passée. C'est des
enfants qui sont sortis cet été,
qui ont été dans les parcs.
Des enfants aussi qui ont revu
les grands-parents,
les familles.
- Les parents de Ricardo ont
compris qu'il faudra faire
les choses différemment.
- Initialement, notre idée,
c'était en janvier, dès qu'on
recommence à travailler, lui
aussi il commence la garderie,
mais à la place, on va
probablement commencer en
novembre même, de manière très
à temps partiel.
- Il faudra y aller de manière
très, très progressive,
je pense.
- Tout en espérant de la
stabilité pour leur bébé puisque
les garderies aux prises avec
une pénurie de personnel.
ICI Anne-Louise Despatie,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.